[Music]
[Music]
they look like something out of an
indiana jones movie
bridges made out of living trees
this is nongriet a remote village in
northeastern india where locals have
been growing bridges for hundreds
[Music]
the head of the village
he's lived here his whole life since
1952.
[Music]
the dream
[Music]
[Music]
to get the roots to grow into a bridge
across water they use wire and old tree
trunks to guide their path
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when a bag is made from a billboard it
has a story
it's creative it's bold
every bag is giving back and it's being
eco-friendly
i was working advertising and i saw that
all the billboards that were going up in
essence were going to the landfill
most people don't know that billboards
are made of vinyl and it can be turned
into something else and so i thought
let's create a business that's
solely based on billboards
on any given month we get close to
around 10 000 pounds of billboards that
we turn into product
once that billboard goes up it's usually
up for a period of about four weeks is
what a typical campaign is on the street
for
[Music]
it's then shipped to our facility here
we sort it we cut it and send it to the
manufacturer where they do the final
sewing and cleaning of the product
we're able to take a billboard that had
one purpose and then reuse it to make
something else
my brother myself are both huge surfers
and we kind of felt like the servant
community loves bright colors and
billboard vinyl is actually very durable
it's a thick material it's waterproof
it's milder proof
so it's actually the perfect material
for a surfboard bag
after that we spent into backpacks
duffel bags wallets fanny packs hip
packs snowboard bags
every product is different every product
is one of a kind
each piece that we make
is unlike anything before it
our playground for all of us is based in
the environment whether it's
the mountains the rivers the the ocean
it's something that we in essence have a
responsibility to maintain and sustain
[Music]
the village of kamikatsu is special
not for its tea fields or idyllic
mountains or peaceful historic homes
it's known for something it doesn't have
kamikatsu as a town produces almost no
trash
[Music]
kamikatsu has a population of roughly 1
500 people and in the 1990s was doing
nearly no recycling
burning all that garbage created carbon
dioxide emissions that became dangerous
and the nature around them was suffering
so a decision was made
kamikatsu had to change
this was the start of their path towards
zero waste and a new way of living
[Music]
effectively what zero waste here means
is that there's no such thing as
throwing something in the trash
everything has to get recycled
and in the beginning it was difficult
for everyone
like mr takuya takaichi he's a shop
owner in kamikazu
[Music]
arena
[Music]
[Music]
she's a housewife
[Music]
[Music]
that classification system she's talking
about is the key to kamikaze's success
and it is aggressive
there are 45 categories of recyclables
[Music]
[Music]
the list it goes on there's 35 more
slowly what was originally this huge
burden became a way of life in kamikatsu
people began looking at trash
differently
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's important to recognize that
kamikaze is a small town it is not like
new york or london the rules are not the
same but there is a constant and that's
people they can change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is not a
landfill this was verseva beach in
mumbai india a little over three years
ago
it was covered in over 6 000 tons of
trash
after what the united nations called the
world's largest beach cleanup this is
versafa beach today
it was a movement started and led by one
man
afros shaw
[Music]
my name is afrosh i'm a lawyer by
profession and i love oceans in october
of 2015 versova beach was little more
than a dumping ground on the west coast
of mumbai there were five and a half
feet
of plastic and when you see so much
plastic object opposed to the ocean it's
scary it's very scary
we have devastated the health of our
ocean
garbage pile up either on land or an
ocean is a big issue not only in india
world over
so afros took matters into his own hands
he started picking up the trash himself
i have spent my childhood here you know
i used to play her and the beach used to
be very very clean for me it was purely
simple it had to be my personal journey
then i told myself it would be difficult
for a single man to do it so i said why
not take this personal journey to others
i provoked others to join in and
eventually they did join me
since 2015 every weekend hundreds of
volunteers join afros to pick up the
trash that has been strewn along a two
mile stretch of the beach
and the volunteer work continues today
we have been cleaning for past 112 weeks
now and it's almost 9 million kgs of
plastic and filter from the ocean beach
cleaning is one of the biggest
preventive action
to prevent this plastic going into the
deep sea this is minimum we can do
so the use of trucks
bulldozers buckets whatever people can
use the beach has slowly been picked up
but the issue is more than just the
beach
it's about the mindset of people so
apart from the beach cleanup afros also
works with local communities to help
educate them on recycling and proper
trash disposal
we go to coastal communities where you
know the littering happens talking to
them i go to people's garbage i tell
them show me
then i tell them how to segregate how to
handle plastic this is the first creek
which is entering into the ocean from
here
i'm proud that i'm connecting with
people and i'm connecting nature that
gets a very big sense of pride in my
heart you know
[Music]
this problem of pollution is created by
us we have lost a sense of belonging to
our planet into our ocean
a lot of people ask me after us how long
you're going to clean
the day we say that this ocean is mine
and it has to be [ __ ] and span will not
ask this question in fact we'll go and
provoke others to do what i'm doing
we are in for a long haul and every
citizen on this planet must be in for a
long haul
start doing your bit what we are doing
[Music]
hey
[Music]